this is the Lin be trail near the little
village of Lindley in Nottingham sure in
England I'm filming on the trail to be
really weird to a walking talk to a
camera on a stick in a little village
this is one of those stories about war
where no one dies no one even gets hurt
and for a little while there's this bit
of light in the middle of something
terrible so World War 2 1941 Britain is
being bombed every night by the
Luftwaffe over in Germany William Joyce
broadcasts freshest propaganda over the
radio to the UK trying to demoralize the
British public the press nicknamed him
Lord haw-haw because of his affected
upper-class accent sometimes Lord
haw-haw would forecast which towns and
places will be bombed next and he was
eerily accurate and on one of his
broadcasts he threatened Lynne be Doc's
dockyards were strategic bombing targets
of course they were but Lynne be Doc's
aren't dockyards at all they're these
little streams that run through the
village of Lindy the docks are just a
local name but Luftwaffe commanders had
looked at the map seen Lynn B docks and
decided to waste some of their limited
war fighting resources on bombing
something that while quite pretty
while strategically useless oh and they
missed the bombs landed a couple of
miles away no one was even slightly hurt
although presumably one farmer's field
had some unexpected and rather violent
plowing down to it it's a lovely story
it's part of the local mythos here in
Lynn B you'll find articles about online
and it's referenced on the love little
parish map that is next the bus shelter
and I'm really really sorry
till in B but I'm not sure it's true
because if you look at the maps from
back then they didn't say Lynn B docks
on them of course they didn't these
streams are so small that they are
barely even marked on the largest scale
maps if Germany was using maps that were
that detailed and that precise well and
they could tell that the docks weren't
big enough to have any ships in them and
if they weren't using maps that detailed
well then the docks wouldn't be marked
on them at all
Lord haw-haw that propaganda broadcaster
he didn't actually give away secret
plans or announce bombing raids in
advance of course he didn't but
Luftwaffe didn't want to give advance
warning so they could be shot down
so we just lied or relied on reports
that came back in the news in the hope
that he would be right enough to
convince the British public who weren't
fools a lot of folks tuned into him a
few million but it was mostly for
entertainment there's an argument that
rubbed and hurt morale he actually
helped British solidarity and there
aren't many recordings up in there
certainly no audio of him saying Lynne
be Doc's that I could find the Blitz was
locked in detail by all the local
authorities and all the records were
compiled Hudnall the nearby town is
mentioned twice but Lynne B isn't
mentioned at all I searched through all
the relevant local newspapers have been
digitized and they have no articles
about any bombings near here I even
asked the local Historical Society and
they were wonderful they went to a lot
of documents for me but there's nothing
from the time that backs it up just
folklore and stories told from parent to
child from elder to youth for maybe the
last 80 years which does hurt a little
cos it's such a wonderful story now if I
present something like this to the world
and say I don't know there's a tendency
for certain over enthusiastic people to
see it as a mystery and try to solve it
the only people who know for sure are
over 90 years old and look no one should
bother them trying to disprove or prove
one bit of local folklore besides I'm
only in the 30s and I've occasionally
had moments where I've recalled clear
memories of things that evidence and
later showed me I have had completely
wrong but the bomb records are not
perfect newspapers back then might not
have mentioned it because bomb lands in
field no one hurt is not a story
at least not 1941 it won't be today
maybe it did happen or maybe someone
came up with a story once told his truth
and everyone thought sure that sounds
fun let's go with it I am expected to
provide evidence for claims rightly so
but there are countless tales that never
happened we call them urban legends or
eventually just legends
did King Alfred really burned the cakes
probably not does it matter
I'll the long enough period of time no
not really
I don't think something like this needs
to be proven or debunked even if it
somehow could
it's just a good story thanks to the
historians and archives who've helped me
with my research I put links in the
description
you